when you were chatting with another
Eastern Orthodox and you brought up
divorce how the Eastern Orthodox is more
lenient towards divorce and that the
Catholic church is more uh strict on it
what did they say yeah and he was like
no no uh God is okay with divorce or
that's what he told me because in the
Bible when Jesus talked I forgot forgive
me for not knowing the verse but he said
uh Matthew 5 it's only accept acceptable
if it's Matthew 31:32 Matthew 19 if you
read verses 1- 12
specifically if you read 7 to2 and then
Mark 10 veres 1- 12 there there talks
about if you've divorced your wife she
divorces you you marry another you
commit adultery
but in Matthew 19 if you read verses 1-
12 specifically if you read 7 to2 and
Matthew 53132 Matthew alone guys I need
you to listen Matthew alone has accept
for sexual
immorality when Mark reports The Words
of Christ Matthew Mark 10 veres 1-2
which is found in Matthew 19 verses 1-2
specifically Matthew 19 verses 1
to9 but I'm saying read 7 to 12 to see
what the Lord says that if you can you
can be celibate if it's your gift and
you don't burn and that's from God
Matthew mentions except for sexual
immorality if a man puts away his wife
and marries another woman except for
sexual immorality he makes the woman an
adulterer and whoever marries that woman
meaning his wife right becomes an
adulterer and she becomes an adulteress
Mark doesn't have the exception Clause
he doesn't say except for sexual
immorality nor does Luke when Luke
mentions in Luke 16:18 let me show it to
you guys watch here you
ready yes so this is baffled Christians
why is it baffled
Christians it did baffle me I'll be
honest shoot you're in good company bro
what do you think you're the only one
this baffle you know it kind of stumped
me you know when I when I brought that
up against that Eastern
Orthodox I'm like what you know does he
allow it like you know yeah watch here
when we read Mark 1010 to12 when they
were in the house again the disciples
asked Jesus about this he answered
anyone who divorces his wife and marries
another woman commits adultery against
no exception Clause no unless if this
happens and if she divorces her husband
and marries another man she commits
adultery
right okay you see that in front of your
eyes yes sir okay do you find an
exception Clause except for sexual
immorality I do not so that means it's a
blanket statement once you're married
that's it you leave for another woman
you're an adulterer she leaves she's an
adulteress right yeah yep I see it yeah
but let me make it a little more
complicated what yeah brother it's not
simple you know how complicated this
issue is I thought I was going to get it
first try all right well here let's see
so if a man divorces his wife and
marries another woman he commits
adultery against his first wife right
right now this leaves open the question
so if the man leaves the wife and
commits adultery does that mean now
she's free to remarry and she be an
adulterous yeah she's not free well how
do you know doesn't say she is or not oh
I guess in the context of this verse
note yeah but if a woman divorces her
husband marries another man she commits
adulter so if she commits adulter does
that mean she's now freed her husband so
he can marry but not her because she's
the one who
divorced I would still yeah I would
reply that it's uh both M it's mutual
they divorc say the man who has been
offended and cheat on is not free after
she commits adultery it doesn't say that
right so how you know I wouldn't know
I'll be honest just given this verse I
wouldn't know but now again like I said
g to make it a little more complex you
ready I'm ready Luke 1618 notice again
anyone who divorces his wife and marries
another woman commits
adultery and the man who marries a
divorced woman commits adultery now this
is harder
yeah if you divorce your wife you marry
another woman you're adulter her but the
divorced
wife the one you divorced she marries
she's an adulterous too you're both
guilty
now yeah yeah that definitely adds to
the other verse right but then Matthew
makes it more
confusing Matthew 19
7-9 why then they asked did Moses
command that a man give his wife a
certificate of dors and send her away
Jesus replied Moses permitted you to
vorce your R because your hearts were
hard because you were hard you were too
corrupt too sinful too weak so God had
to take it easy with you until he
elevates you but it was not this way
from the beginning now here's the
confusion I tell you that anyone who
divorces his wife except for sexual
immorality now there's an exception
Clause
yep and Mary's another woman commits
adultery meaning if my wife cheats on me
if I read it this way I cannot divorce
my wife unless she's committed sexual
immorality so if she's committed
sexuality does that mean I can divorce
her and walk
away it sounds like
yeah all right except for you well
depends on who you ask and how you
understand us culturally now here
Matthew
53132 okay guys you're listening
it has been said Jesus speaking anyone
divorces his wife must give her
certificate divorce but I tell you that
anyone divorces his wife except for
sexual
immorality makes her listen to
this makes her the victim of adultery
and when marries a divorce woman commits
adultery now it's really bad so if I
divorce my wife who hasn't been sexually
Unfaithful and I move on
now if she goes ahead married I now made
her an
adulteress yeah and if you marry that
divorced woman you're an
adulterer oh yeah I can see it yeah I
know what yeah now you see how
complicated is right yeah that's
definitely adds each verse adds an extra
layer of uh comp
complexity as far as like understanding
it more deep
MH and like the yeah the prohibit
prohibits and what's acceptable yeah
again listen guys this one says if I am
a Christian man married to a Christian
woman I divorce
her and she goes and marry someone else
she's now an adulteress and the man who
marries an adulterer even though I
divorced her but then it says except for
sexual immorality does that
mean if I divorce my wife because she
was sexually Unfaithful I am free and
she's
not no right I don't know what are you
talking about you like I got the answer
I feel like you were coming to that
answer I'll be honest I wasn't I was
telling you how complex the issues are
all right then if we add Paul Romans 7
verses
1-3 Paul do you not know brothers
sisters for I'm speaking those who know
the law he's not saying the law of Moses
that the law has authority over someone
only as long as that person
if you're alive you're bound to the law
but if you're dead you're free from the
law right right okay so as long as I'm
alive I'm bound to the
law that law is authority over someone
only as long as the person lives for
example by law a married woman is bound
to husband as long as he is
alive but if her husband dies she is
released from the law that binds her to
him no exception Clause as long as
you're both alive you are bound to each
other until one of you die so then if
she has sex relations with another man
while her husband's still alive she's
called an adulterous but if her husband
dies she's released from the law and is
not adulterous if she marries another
man he's saying the law of Moses right
yeah okay here he says you're bound but
we know that's not the case because
Deuteronomy 25 tells us I'm sorry
Deuteronomy 24 veres 1 and4 tells us
that Moses said when you give your wife
a certificate of divorce right yep she
marries another man you can't take her
back right that's what it says yeah so
la la Moses says no there are situations
when you can divorce and you will
divorce but Paul says the law says
you're bound to you die because Paul is
simply giving you what we call a
summation he's not going into detail
he's not giving you the ground well
there are exceptions he's just getting
to the point if I'm married she's
married we're bound together until one
of us die so his whole point
is you and I if we're married to a women
the law says we are bound till we die
and only when we die we're freed but we
know Paul can't be perverting the law he
knows the law so obviously he simply
generalized
because Paul is not then taking
consideration well what if the wife does
X is the man bound well Paul knew very
well as a rabbi there were two schools
of thought saying if your wife did
something she then violated the marital
Covenant the marriage contract but you
see how complex it
gets yeah it does it does get complex
you're right all right you thought that
was complex all right okay I was R
there's more Yep First Corinthians but
wait there's more that's right I'm used
to saying these things because you know
every person has his
own unique you know expressions and
idioms like with William I'm pumped I'm
thrilled
right 1 Corinthians 7:10 to1 you ready
let's
go now guys watch how more confusing
gets he's saying the Lord Jesus while he
was on Earth said this about Believers
to the married I give this Command right
not I but the Lord the Lord while on
Earth is giving these commands he
addressed this issue a wife must not
separate from her
husband but if she does she must remain
unmarried or else be reconciled husband
did you catch it if you're two Believers
baptized believers who know Christ all
you can do is remain separate or return
but you can't divorce and remarry that's
what Paul said Jesus taught but if she
does she must remain unmarried or else
be reconciled to husband and husband
must not divorce his wife period end of
story no exception you don't want to
give him two options
there what do we
do you you you tell me Sam help me out
here it depends on the church you belong
to why even oh yeah you're right I
forgot yeah you're I guess I see your
point yeah I see your point Apostolic
churches yeah they also
differ because why this is an indication
that there may have been some confusion
even among the early Christians because
they may not have gotten Clarity from
the apostles because remember some
issues were more important than other
issues not that marriage isn't important
so as these issues came to the Forefront
and they became more pressing marriage
you know received into the
background right because they had other
issues to do with like dotism and
gnosticism and so on and so forth so
that by the time things
became much more relax and they can
focus on more practical theology
practical application this is where this
is where the Christians would agree to
disagree and have difference of opinion
no Catholic Orthodox believes that all
Christians everywhere were unanimous in
every Doctrine nobody believes that so
the teaching goes like this when we see
Christians unanimously in unanimity
saying X we take that as being a
teaching by the spirit because the
spirit will make sure that the church
does not agree on error and if we find
that a majority of Christians believe X
we will side with the majority because
it's less likely the majority will be
wrong than the minority unless we have
strong reasons that the majority was
influenced by one opinion whereas the
minority go have an opinion that's older
you want me there I see you yeah the
third is when we see no majority or no
unanimity but they're all disagreeing
that means the spirit is giving freedom
to agree to
disagree and the spirit is not making it
dogmatic you want me there yeah the
spirit is is only is working more when
everybody's in agreement mean it's not
that he's working it means the spirit
wanted them to all agree on this okay
but in these other areas the spirit
allowed freedom because even Romans 14
Paul talks about that in Christ we have
freedoms so that one man can sayi eat
all Meats another one says no I won't
eat all meats and he goes you're both
free
you can do what you want in Christ
that's WR so here we're already told in
the Bible Romans 14 there are certain
areas where the spirit doesn't allow
dogmatism he allows Freedom that's in
Romans 14 Paul says it some people eat
all Meats some say you shouldn't eat all
Meats he didn't say who was wrong he
said they're both
free do what you want so if you say I'm
going to be a vegetarian amen I'm going
to eat sausage pizza glory to God but
Paul said though don't use your freedom
to oppress or alienate or demonize so
the point is the fact we have a
disagreement amongst Orthodox Catholic
means this is what would have been a
teaching that wasn't solidly defined and
dogmatized allowing Christians to
explore argue and disagree that's all I
can tell you so who's right whoever
church that the spirit tells you to too
you gotta agree with them yeah yeah I
mean you got to stand with the church
you're in right yeah you can't go you
compromise then you're like essentially
allowing the other Church to like
convince you that they might be right
and you're causing division so why are
you there I agree with you 100% yeah
that's what Martin Luther
did that's what like the church was
running so he decided you know what I'm
going to break off and start my own
church and then he saw the chaos and the
hell that resulted Protestants are all
over the map but even with the apostolic
Traditions they're not
unanimous Catholics say that if you have
a sacramental marriage
right you
divorce you can't remarry now someone
sent me a whole lengthy comment he's
listening that there are certain
exceptions even for sacramental
marriages all right it becomes more
complex in the orth Orthodox tradition I
was told that the first marriage is
sacramental now if you've been divorced
for sexual immorality you can have a
second marriage but it doesn't have the
status of the first you can even have a
third marriage but it doesn't have the
status of the second and that's it if
it's for reasons of immorality that's
what I've been told so I don't know so
if you think I'm going to solve it it's
like you ask me to solve the filio ain't
going to happen on my watch I don't know
what the answer is so you just follow
the teachings of your church